مرحبا اهلا بك هل نبدا بالربيع رمضان كريم
اهلا بك نبدا بالاجواء لحولك هند الربيع
الذي دق ابواب باكرا في واشنطن نيويورك
اشجار الكرز اذا تفتح في واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اهلا سهام ونادين رمضان كريم عليكم وعلى
جميع مشاهدينا طبعا
الطقوس الرمضانيه قليله نوعا ما في واشنطن
لكن الجميل ان هذا العام جاء تزامن قدوم
رمضان الشهر المبارك مع عوده الربيع
والتفتح اشجار الكرز التي يعني تحيط بنا
الان هذه الاشجار وهي هديه من اليابان
للولايات المتحده تستدعي الى نوع من
التعبد ايضا ان صح التعبير هناك كلمه
يابانيه اسمها هناامي وهي تعني تامل تفتح
هذه الاشجار ومحاوله الى التامل في الخلق
ومدى كيفيه ان الحياه الثانيه طبعا هنا في
نحن حول ما يعرف بالتايلر بيزن وهو حوض
المد والجزر تقريبا 3 كلم حول زي البحيره
الصغيره تقريبا 4000 شجره من اشجار الكرز
ولكن هذه هي اشجار الكرز الزينه وليست
اشجار الكرز الفاكهه
هناك
بنفس المكان هناك مجموعه من النسب
التذكاريه اهمها طبعا واكبرها هو نصب
الرئيس السابق جيفرسن كما ان هناك
نصب لمارتر لوثر كينج واعمال فنيه اخرى
منحوسات وتماثيل يعني حمضة الى وجود مصباح
نعم هند حقيقه الاجواء رائعه نحن نشاهد
اشجار الكرز المهدا من اليابان اذا ذهبنا
قليلا وبعيدا ليس بالكثير من اليابان
الصيد هذه المره والصين وامريكا يعود
التجاذب من جديد يا هند وهذه المره تيك
توك بين البلدين ما جديد هذه المره فيما
يتعلق بتيك توك وتجاذبات الاخيره خصوصا ان
هذا التطبيق الذي بلغ عدد مستخدمين في
امريكا 150 مليون مستخدم
صحيح صحيح هؤلاء ال 150 مليون من
المناهضين لاحتمال ان يحضر هذا التطبيق
المهم طبعا بالامس كان قد قال كبير النائب
رئيس في مجلس النواب تحدث عن انه هناك
احتمال كبير ان تسير الامور وفق يعني بعد
بعد استماع جلسه الاستماع التي قام فيها
الرئيس التنفيذي لتيكتاك ليبدو انها زادت
الطين بله واعاده بعض المخاوف للمشرعين
الامريكيين خاصه وطبعا القلق الاساسي له
علاقه بالبيانات بيانات المستخدمين وكان
من مقارثه قال يبدو ان المشرعين قد يميلوا
الى حظر هذا التطبيق في الولايات المتحده
خاصه وهناك يعني قلق من ان يقوم يعني بما
ان الصين لديها
حصه كبيره في في هذا البرنامج قد يكونوا
من المتابع للمعلومات والمعلومات
والبيانات الامريكيين وقلق من ان تستخدم
هذه البيانات للتاثير على الراي الامريكي
خاصه في ايام الانتخابات ويعني الراي
الامريكي سواء مع اي حزب ضد اي حزب اخر
والحكومه الامريكيه هي كانت منعت وجود هذا
التطبيق في الهواتف التابعه للحكومه لاي
موظفي الحكومه والان تسعى لحظر هذا
البرنامج
لجميع الامريكيين اما حضروا او بيع الاسهم
للشركه امريكيه ويبدو ان الامور تسير صوب
حظر هذا
التطبيق المهم لكن هناك طبعا في الشارع
الامريكي من يعني يقوم ضد يناهض هذا
القرار الامريكي كما ذكرتي هناك اكثر من
150 مليون امامي
شهريا تقريبا يعني سينتفض المراهقون
وسيكون سينزل في الشارع على كل حال للحديث
تتمه دائما
شكرا جزيلا لك هند ابراهيم